les chéris on est venu chercher vous
vous cherchez ou bien vous avez on vous
a repéré ou vous avez vous-même des
marchés pour faire la star acade ça
dépend moi on a on m'a repéré après
c'est tous les tous les castings bah sur
les réseaux et vous avez sorti des
petits trucs aussi en indépendance donc
après on a passé le casting
daté ils ont ils ont craqué pour toi
vous êtes pas trop triste de sortir je
vous sens un peu triste quand même bah
c'est sûr qu'on a un peu décembre on va
pas dire qu'on est content d'être sorti
mais après c'est c'est le jeu il fallait
un duo éliminé ça a été nous mais on a
vécu trois semaines tellement intense et
je pense qu'on est gagnant dès le début
en fait on m'a dit tu es prise c'est bon
j'ai gagné
alors Carla je te dis tout il y a eu
beaucoup de rumeurs qui disent il y a
des gens qui disaient que tu étais
pistonnés qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est
quoi ces rumeurs là c'est des rumeurs
complètement fausses parce que j'ai pas
été pistonné et oui je pense que ça
parle de Yanis tout ça mais je n'ai pas
du tout été pistonné pour faire la Star
Academy non ouais parce que comme vous
avez vécu la séquence polémique dans
l'or embrouille Julien enfin là la prof
c'est vrai que ça fait énormément parler
moi j'ai dit voilà c'est c'est un truc
voilà c'est vrai que Gilles était vent
debout comme d'habitude pour rien
vous est-ce que vous avez été choqué
alors on peut la revoir la séquence vous
l'avez ou pas en régie vous l'avez pas
la séquence vous êtes mort original oh
j'enlève l'oreillette vous servent à
rien merci
alors vous avez dit quoi
pas forcément choqué honnêtement dans
notre posture en fait on voit une prof
un élève qui font leur rôle chacun l'un
l'autre et
sur le coup nous on n'a pas on n'a pas
accepté en fait
on n'a pas on n'a pas trouvé l'ordre
trop violente avec Julien elle a été
maladroite sur certains propos mais
après nous on n'a pas trouvé enfin sur
le coup on sait pas dit c'était quelque
chose de grave en fait c'est après qu'on
a vu la panique mais il se passe un truc
de fou non non elle joue son rôle de
prof elle est tellement bienveillante
avec nous on sait qu'elle sera jamais
dans la méchanceté
alors elles ont dit sur le coup mais
après quand vous avez vu la polémique
est-ce que là vous trouvez qu'elle est
allée trop loin
on a besoin de secouer les élèves je
sais que moi parfois quand je me fais
secouer ça me fait du bien après je dis
pas
plus intelligent je dis pas que Julien
méritait d'être secouer franchement j'ai
pas j'ai pas d'avis à voir je suis pas
au dessus de lui pour parler mais par
contre je trouve qu'ils avaient fait un
laver son rôle de prof il avait son rôle
d'élève nous on est là on est dans notre
bulle c'est vrai peut-être qu'on le vit
différemment de ce que vous vivez à
l'extérieur quand vous regardez quoi
mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux est-ce que vous
êtes vraiment coupé du monde à la star
parce qu'il y a une rumeur sur un
téléphone portable qui circulait dans le
château pour vous
montrer
ah non allez prime c'est un truc de fou
de voir des gens qui parlent on voit nos
proches dans le public on voit des gens
ça nous fait bizarre mais c'est vraiment
le téléphone une minute une minute ça
nous rend Malte vous voyez à la télé
c'est vraiment il y a rien d'autre tout
ça le producteur de la star avec
l'embrasse d'ailleurs moi Jean-Louis